We've seen this picture a few times, let's talk about how our
algorithm is going to change. So what we're going to do is you know,
user makes the, makes a request. We go to the database, we
run the query, we get the results out we store them in
the cache. And then we return the HTML to the user, that's
kind of our standard use case and then any future requests Hit
ASCII chan, bounce off the cache and come back. Now, we're going to
improve the situation a little bit. So that when you do a database
write, so we post a new piece of art. And we do our write to the database.
At the same time, we're going to clear
our cache. So that after we've redirected user to
the front page. And the user fetches Slash
again. We're going to run our query, we're going to get
our result, we're going to re-cache the new version, which
has you know, multiple things in it, and then
return correct HTML to our user. So, let's go ahead
and see how that looks in the code. Okay, now
despite the complexity of that picture This is actually a
fairly easy change. Our rendering front page doesn't change at
all. And our top arts function that runs the cache
database query. This also doesn't change at all. The only
thing is going to change, is when we submit new
art which is in this function here, the post function.
After we put this art in the database. Let's just
clear our cache. Which looks something like this. Cache.clear. Clear is
a function on Python dictionaries that just basically empties the
dictionary.cl In our case, this will work just fine, because we're
only storing one thing in the cache. So we, it's,
it's fine to just delete everything. Alternatively, of course, we could
have just said cache, you know, top, equals none, something
like that. But, let's go with the simple solution for now.
Okay, so let's see how this works. So here we are. I'm
going to reload our front page of Ascii Chan. We see our beer is
here now because I changed the app so our cache got cleared
anyway. If we go to our terminal, we see that our most request
did a database query, and if I go back to Ascii Chan.
Reload the page again, and then go back to our terminal. We can
see that our most recent request did not make a DB query. So,
that's pretty cool. So our caching is still working on our front page.
Now let's submit a new piece of art to ASCIIchan and see
if the site still works. I'm going to put a few blank lines
here so we can see where we were when we come back
to this. Okay, so here we are in ASCII chan. Let's go
ahead and submit a new piece of art. In this case it's
going to be a cake. Now, what should happen is we're going to store
this in a database, clear the cache, reload the page, update the
cache, and have our new piece of cake. Okay, so I submitted and
now we see our cake is here. Let's go ahead and look at our terminal to see all
these requests. Okay, so we can see our post
here. That was the submission and then we responded with
the 302 which is the redirect and we can
see we print off db query and we see our
front page request and all is well. Now if
I were to reload our page again, here we go,
and go back to the terminal we could see the follow up
request didn't hit the database. So, now we've got this cool system.
When we submit to the database, we clear the cache, and then
the next time we hit the front page, we rerun the query and
every page after that doesn't hit the database anymore. So now we're
doing only as many database queries as we actually need, and so every
user to Ascii Chan wont have to hit the database unless there's
a new submission for them. This is going to cut down on our database
requests substantially. You know, instead of doing one database
read on every page view, we're only doing one
database read on every submission, which happens far less
frequently. Okay, so we implemented our new algorithm and
before in the original algorithm we were doing one
DB ready per page view. This is really bad.
You know, this is doing a lot of unnecessary
database reads. The name of the game when you're scaling
websites, is only do the minimum number of database
operations that you need to. And in this case,
one read per page view is the opposite of
that. After our solution, we're only doing one DB read
per submission, and since submissions are rare, you know,
most of our users, you know, the vast majority
of them, aren't submitting new content. They're just reading
content. We've cut down the number of database operations we're
doing significantly. So when you're looking for speed and you're
looking for sufficiency and you're looking to not spend all of
your money paying for database access, this is a much
better approach than this one. You know, if we're getting a
thousand page views a day. And ten submissions today, we
went from 1000 DB reads to ten. That's a big improvement.
And those are approximately the real numbers from ASCII chan, so,
you know, we just saved Steve a bunch of coin here,
so, good job, everybody.